at least a few victims of the Louisiana
flooding seemed thrilled to see Donald
Trump show up there with Mike Pence in
Louisiana they acted like Trump was
actually doing something to make a
difference and here's people saying we
knew you'd be here Donald take a look
well yeah he's not gonna miss an
opportunity for just a blatant pandering
photo op anybody could have predicted
Trump was gonna show up there yeah and
uh server mission accomplished it worked
so then Trump uh well before I get to
the video of Trump quote helping I'll
show you this is a guy who teared up at
Trump showing up in his private plane
with a make America great again huh give
me a minute I can give him four or five
hours but he didn't give me a minute yet
but hopefully one day he will if he sees
this go are you happy that he came here
oh yes sir most blessed with it yeah
doubt no down trump all the way hey
everybody wait why did you lose and what
does it mean tap the whole trunk here
let's see
I didn't lose anything appeared
to what a lot of people lost I'm okay
it's materialistic things they do
replace having some hear that mentality
oh yes yes big ol l America's gotta wake
up right so here is the big photo op op
Trump spending basically 45 seconds
handing out items uh just helping to
move items off of the back of a truck
and into someone else's hands and uh
this this is the entire thing this is
Trump helping take a look they go on lot
of work Trump is doing there huh he is
absolutely moving boxes applies be
starting to break a sweat yeah very
somber and serious Donald Trump showing
up here uh yeah so anyway I don't know I
mean is this is that helping I've seen
so many people posting about how Trump
is helping the guys in a suit wearing a
make America great again had how much
help do you really think he's doing in
flood recovery what about writing a
check Donald but that's really been the
problem for Trump right he talks a lot
about the charity contributions he makes
Washington Post investigation turned out
uh up that he actually maybe at most two
donated $10,000 a tiny tiny seedling of
a fraction of what he claimed to have
donated that's really what he could have
done written a check do you think with
all the money he saved by not paying
people who worked for him he got more
generous with charity uh well he is
helping in the ended by definition
literal sense yeah I guess he did help
for a few minutes there right wingers
Jason are furious because all bomb is on
vacation during this time he's not doing
anything first of all uh presidents can
work from anywhere Bush was on vacation
during any number of train wrecks and
disasters that took place and you didn't
hear the
Republicans criticizing him for that but
President Obama did actually declare a
disaster he issued a disaster
declaration which allows Louisiana and
people in Louisiana to apply for federal
aid isn't that such a flaccid criticism
will wear it where is Obama he's
vacationing Trump is here with a suit
passing around soap I'm sure Obama's
actually doing more by not being there
and actually like communicate with
people and setting up organizations get
things done and Donald Trump a shows up
and move the box from side to side later
check Donald that's not it's not a photo
op for Obama yeah that's exactly right
President Obama is not taking this as an
opportunity to be photographed holding
but soap boxes